[Música]
de chiquita solía gustarme mucho la
magia a veces en la tele pasaban a un
show de cor perfil y hay un truco que en
particular me encantaba el tipo
arrancaba diciendo les invito a que lo
hagan hará conmigo
el truco cierren los ojos y concéntrese
bien piensen en un número del 0 al 9
ahora multiplica en por 9 ese número el
resultado va a ser de dos dígitos les
pido que sumen entre sí esos dos dígitos
y les dio 12 1 + 2 a ese valor res
telecinco
y el número que obtienen asociando con
la letra que le corresponde del
abecedario si les dio uno lo asocian a
letras
les pido que con esa letra piensen en un
país que empiece con esa letra
la letra que le sigue del abecedario
les pido que con esta letra piensen en
un animal
y ahora un color parece animal
entonces pasan unos segundos y coperfil
decía
debe haber un error porque no hay
elefantes grises en dinamarca a memoria
loca pero no me sorprendía tanto como
hacía como perfil para obligarnos a
tener que elegir un animal con la letra
es lo que más me impacta era como se
había que ir a pensar en un elefante y
es curioso porque ahora pienso lo
contrario no es obvio que todas todos y
todos vamos a pensar en un elefante
entiendo ahora que no estábamos ante un
acto de magia porque lo que hacía
copperfield era el acto de predecir y de
eso les voy a hablar hoy de la
predicción se preguntarán qué tiene que
ver la proyección en una charla curso
título versa sobre feminismo y cerebro
bueno créanme que el sistema de
predicción tiene estrecha relación con
el sistema de sexo género y para
contarles porque voy a comenzar
narrándoles lo que me sucedió hace unos
años
descubrí algo en mi cuerpo pero no lo
descubrí porque era nuevo y no había
aparecido de repente no lo tuve siempre
conmigo
más aún me di cuenta que a todas las
personas con un tiro como yo les pasó lo
mismo
tengo próstata
la próstata de los cuerpos con útero
debe haber tenido su personería jurídica
podríamos decir en torno al año 2004
ahora como puede ser que tantos años de
investigación sobre el cuerpo humano con
tanto soporte tengan nivel tecnológico
nos enteramos recién ahora quizás habían
olvidado ya avisar
pero no ahí me di cuenta lo que
significa la expresión que el mundo es
'no androcéntrico el androcentrismo es
la descripción del mundo incluyendo a
nuestro cuerpo a través de la mirada del
varón
pero no les hablo de cualquier varón les
hablo de un tipo de varón blanco de
clase media occidental heterosexual
isis
si es el prefijo para señalar a las
personas que se identifican con el
género o sexo que les fue asignado al
nacer cuando una persona es is significa
que no es trans y acá es donde primero
vemos algo esencial para que el mundo
androcéntrico funcione y es el sistema
predictivo que desarrolla
porque porque seguramente si les
pregunto a qué identidad asociaron la
palabra útero sea la identidad mujer no
eso es un rasgo si se exista propio del
sistema predictivo
si se exista porque porque suponemos que
todas las personas con un cierto sistema
reproductor van a identificarse
unívocamente con la categoría mujer
vagina se convierte en equivalente a
mujer y no cualquier mujer hablamos de
lo femenino no cierta estética
determinadas conductas probablemente no
nos imaginamos a esa mujer escupiendo en
la calle o trabajando en un taller
mecánico
aunque ahora que lo pienso por ahí la
imaginamos en la pared del taller
mecánico
pero vamos a ir prediciendo
les pido que imaginen a una persona
besándose con esa típica mujer
probablemente sea un varón
y ese es otro rasgo del sistema
predictivo la heteronormatividad
pensamos creemos que todas las personas
somos heterosexuales
este es un problema el de la predicción
y realmente conocemos personas que
rompen con esa lógica como varones trans
que tienen útero mujeres y con estética
masculina personas que se identifican
como gays lesbianas bisexuales etcétera
pero en este sistema predictivo las
clasificamos de minorías
las clasificamos siempre como si fueran
minorías estamos en un sistema de
valores donde la anatomía y la
fisiología determinan nuestras prácticas
sociales fíjense todo lo que predice la
genitalidad nuestra identidad de género
si vamos a ser varones o mujeres cómo
vamos a expresar esa identidad a través
de qué vestimentas actividades intereses
y cuál va a estar nuestra orientación
sexual es decir hacia quiénes nos vamos
a sentir atraídas hacia traídos
históricamente el discurso científico
acerca de la diferencia sexual argumentó
biológicamente la justificación de las
relaciones de opresión
varones y sobre mujeres y personas sis
sobre personas trans personas
heterosexuales sobre personas gay
lesbianas bisexuales personas blancas
sobre personas negras
actualmente las neurociencias continúan
esta legitimidad porque porque sostienen
que existen dos cerebros como el
discurso biomédico sesgadamente insiste
en que sólo hay dos formas en
genitalidad para las neurociencias hay
una diferenciación cerebral que ocurre
en el estadio fetal y produce dos
cerebros varón o mujer
cada cerebro tiene habilidades
específicas por ejemplo el cerebro del
varón tiene mayor optimizada una
habilidad de llamada visoespacial es
decir va a encontrar más fácil donde
dejó estacionado el auto o tiene ciertas
facilidades para la química orgánica y
ciertas ingenierías
en contraste el cerebro de la mujer va a
estar optimizado para una habilidad de
llamada fluida es verbal no sé si les
suena
además de habilidades estas diferencias
cerebrales se explican conductas por
ejemplo que la cne analiza la muñeca
el nene el camión y la lucha fíjense
entonces que esta lectura de los
cerebros no es sólo dicotómica varón o
mujer además esta lectura de los
cerebros es jerárquica porque las
habilidades y conductas que están
optimizadas en el cerebro masculino son
las más valoradas en el mundo
androcéntrico el cerebro del varón está
facilitado para la abstracción el
razonamiento la destreza técnica y la
fortaleza en contraste el cerebro de la
mujer está facilitado para la
comunicación la empatía la emoción
[Música]
y para el cuidado
fíjense que reproducimos constantemente
esta lectura de los cerebros en nuestras
prácticas también hay dos conductas más
que están asociadas a esta
diferenciación cerebral la identidad de
género y la orientación sexual
es decir que los cerebros serían sis y
heterosexuales entonces hay una
creciente ola de investigaciones
neurocientíficas buscando las causas
neurobiológicas de la transexualidad y
de la homosexualidad se buscan los
componentes del sexo opuesto en esos
cerebros en contraste con esta lectura
dicotómica existe una línea de trabajo
llevada adelante por la investigadora de
afna joel que muestra la invalidez de
clasificar los cerebros de acuerdo al
criterio varón mujer porque si bien los
genes y las hormonas que asociamos a
nuestro sexo evidentemente impactan en
nuestra constitución cerebral no la
determinan son un factor más entre otros
entre otros que van desde genes y
hormonas no asociadas a los sexos
pasando por el ambiente como el clima
hasta llegar a nuestras prácticas
sociales
y esto es congruente con lo que nos
caracteriza como especie que es nuestra
alta plasticidad cerebral la facilidad
con que incorporamos experiencia a
nuestro cableado neuronal el cerebro
aprende a través de la experiencia y
centren a través de la repetición y es
curioso que la investigadora janet fyle
encontró que las habilidades
visuoespaciales mejoran con el
entrenamiento
un tipo de actividad que las mejoras
saben cuál es los videojuegos
a qué género asociamos los videojuegos
como socializamos nuestras prácticas
nuestros intereses están normados por
los roles de género si hubiera
diferencias entonces para las
habilidades visuoespaciales o en la
elección del juguete entre varones y
mujeres no estamos entre causas de una
programación biológica innata sino ante
consecuencias de nuestras prácticas
normadas por los roles de género pero
recuerden que yo él dijo que el inválido
clasificar los cerebros de acuerdo al
criterio varón mujer y esto es porque
existe tanta variabilidad entre los
cerebros de varones y mujeres como entre
los cerebros de mujeres por un lado y
los cerebros de varones por otro lado es
decir que las normas de género son
trascendidas por nuestra singularidad
cada cerebro es único les pido que
retengan esta idea y vamos a volver a
los elefantes es evidente que hay otros
animales que empiezan con la letra e
pero no pensamos en ellos y no haber
pensado en ellos no significa que la eco
en la que empiezan sea menos válida o no
pensamos en ellos porque son menos
el único motivo por el cual lo pensamos
en ellos es cultural
estamos familiarizadas y familiarizados
con el elefante y no porque
cotidianamente los veamos incluso por
ahí personalmente nunca conocimos uno
pero los incorporamos en el cotidiano a
través por ejemplo en los medios de
comunicación walt disney dumbo
como los escarabajos y los escorpiones
otros animales que empiezan con la letra
e las personas trans
o gay lesbianas bisexuales transexuales
no estamos representadas en el
imaginario social no por ser minoría de
hecho no sabemos cuántas personas
visibilizan expresan o se permiten
cuestionar sus propios deseos no estamos
representadas en el imaginario social
por lo que significa en nuestros cuerpos
y prácticas una contradicción para el
sistema predictivo
de sexo género
entonces se nos etiqueta de minorías
para asociarnos a la idea de desvío
excepción y se reafirma este hecho
recurriendo a la comparación con otras
especies interpretando que son naturales
y a su vez asociando lo natural a lo
normal porque ese es otro rasgo
característico del mundo androcéntrico
lo natural equivale a lo normal
pero les pregunto qué es lo natural
somos personas que nos maquillamos
usamos tacos nos depilamos nos afeitamos
fumamos todas las acciones que sabemos
que no son naturales y sin embargo no
pensamos personas normales salvo que
esas acciones no sean ejecutadas por el
género correspondiente si no fuera parte
de un disfraz que un varón se tacos es
raro porque no es masculino
entonces fíjate fíjense que lo que no es
normal no es aquello no natural es
aquello que no se ajusta a los
estereotipos de género
y los estereotipos son el aprendizaje de
un conjunto de hábitos y conductas que
nos dicen que podemos hacer
no somos naturales
somos culturales
y los estereotipos aplastan nuestra
subjetividad
y eso es el patriarcado no es un señor
enorme que señala con el dedo quienes
van a ser las personas más privilegiadas
el patriarcado que consiste en un
sistema de valores del que les hable
este que nos hace etiquetar de minorías
identidades y prácticas que no se
ajustan a los estereotipos de género
este que prescribe nuestra conducta ese
que nos enseñó que la razón está por un
lado y la emoción está por el otro
eso es el régimen patriarcal
entonces para poder romper con ese
régimen tenemos que empezar cuestionando
nuestra propia subjetiva
plantearnos preguntarnos quiénes
queremos ser qué deseamos
no hay cerebros rosas y cerebros
celestes
cada una de nosotras las personas
tenemos el potencial para colorear el
cerebro con los colores que queramos
el régimen sexual patriarcal identifica
y clasifica para controlar
para limitar nuestras potencialidades
pero ya lo sabemos
no hay razón ni sociedad de emoción
nadie nace trans ni nadie nace sis
nadie nace gay lesbiana o bisexual
porque nadie nace de lo sexual
y esto es por una sencilla razón
nadie nace varón ni nadie nace mujer
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]